in a surprise move defying agreements
already made with the EU British
lawmakers gave the Prime Minister a
mandate to go back to the negotiating
table parliamentarians narrowly passed a
government-backed amendment to change
the Irish backstop it buys me some time
but the challenges remained clear such a
change in the EU in negotiating it will
not be easy
[Applause]
but in contrast to a fortnight ago this
house has made it clear what it needs to
approve a withdrawal agreement may's
chances of achieving that appear slim
the EU says the backstop a plan to avoid
a hard border between Northern Ireland
and the Republic of Ireland isn't up for
renegotiation
I think the backstop is what is an
insurance and an insurance is needed to
be 100% sure that there is no border
between Northern Ireland and Irish
Republic and we don't want ourselves
that the backstop is is uses president
of the European Council Donald Tusk also
immediately announced that the EU was
not prepared to reopen discussions while
French president macron lent his voice
in support of no renegotiation as the
European Council of December has clearly
indicated the withdrawal agreement that
has been negotiated between the United
Kingdom and the European Union is the
best agreement possible and is not
negotiable
with the --use brexit negotiator Michel
Barnier
also defending the existing deal Theresa
May is poised to travel to Brussels on
what could be mission impossible she may
come back with nothing new to what the
Parliament which means back to square
one for brexit again
let's bring in DW London correspondent
Bergen Mass so you're good help us make
sense of this because the e the UK
excuse me they're asking to reopen
negotiations on a deal that took 18
months to agree what are the chances of
the EU giving the UK any more
concessions that depends on who you ask
here in Britain many - they're on the
right of threes Amaze party have really
pushed for her to be tougher on the
European Union and they have really said
to her she needs to go back they don't
believe what Brussels are saying they
don't believe that they are never going
to give in and not drope and their
withdrawal agreement they think that
they really want to avoid Britain
crashing out with that idea they say
they want the money from the UK and that
they in the end that they will budge so
is
a game of chicken they think where the
UK should just be tough on on the
European Union I've spoken to Dominic
Rob the former brexit secretary he's
somebody who's always urged to resume to
be really much stronger and much tougher
against the European Union and this is
what he had to say how he explained his
thinking we want to do a deal with our
EU friends and our German friends and
our friends across Europe and of course
no deal would be have some significant
implications for German businesses
livelihoods and jobs as well as here in
the UK so as a deal to be done but you
can't keep saying no every reasonable
proposal the the UK makes they need to
reciprocate the flexibility that we've
shown and if that happens and we have
some pragmatism within the Commission
and cost capitals this deal will get
done if not we will leave on WTO terms
on the 29th of March so this is Dominic
Robb and there are others of course in
the houses of parliament who say them is
just chasing unicorns will be here in
two weeks time and she'll come back and
she will have got nothing from the
European Union and it'll be Groundhog
Day so it really depends on who you
speak to in Westminster so what are the
next steps then for Theresa May Bergen
well Theresa May is now going back to
Brussels and she's going to try and get
some flexibility as Dominic rabe and
others are hoping on the issue of are
that other so-called backstop issue and
then she's going to come back here to to
London and present this hopefully as she
hopes new deal to the Parliament then if
she doesn't get anything then the
question is what happens then there is
always the hope from the Labour Party
that there might be a general election
in the end and there are also others who
are still hoping that there might be a
second referendum of a vote on on the
deal and I've spoken to Vince Cable the
leader of the Liberal
here in London and he said he still
thinks that this is the most likely
option or that this is one of the very
likely options so in reality we are none
the wiser to resume first has to go to
Brussels come back and then we can well
we'll take it from there there's more
work to be done there get mass in London
thank you so what does all of this mean
let's get the European angle on what was
decided in London yesterday DW is makea
the corner is at the German government's
committee at Foreign Affairs in Berlin
max Hoffman is joining us from Brussels
good morning to you both Michaela I'd
like to begin with you the British
Parliament wants a different deal what's
the reaction in Berlin well the reaction
buttons that they'll simply won't be one
and there's a sense of frustration also
that once again the British Parliament
didn't make clear what it actively wants
it once again voted against something
which is the brexit well which is no
brexit scenario and also this called
backstop insurance policy and I did get
the chance to talk to several committee
members amongst them although they he's
a better from the conservative CDU party
this is what he had to say well I think
it's the wrong approach from the United
Kingdom and his resume is under pressure
so I can understand that she would like
to negotiate as far as possible however
we have another eight weeks and we
should really avoid a heartbreaks it and
we should invest all our engagement to
keep a kind of tariffs and customs union
and nothing else there will be no
further room of manoeuvre so let's put
it this way even the far-right AFD party
stopped short of making it an aim for
Germany to leave the European Union and
even if Germany did so the far-right AFD
which often talks to Nigel Farage in
Britain would be against a No Deal
scenario so that much for theory but
there's also a lot of belief in the
endless creativity of Brussels of course
and which is where we're going to go
next where Max Wolfman is standing by so
Max I mean what's the take there because
you know very much the message from
Brussels to
London was figure out what you guys want
and now may seems to finally have a
clear mandate and idea of what she can
get past her Parliament is the EU gonna
give her what she needs
it's gonna come a little clearer Sarah
what the House of Commons in the UK
actually went but it's kind of
contradictory but one thing is clear
they don't like the backstop so the
insurance policy to avoid a hard border
between Northern Ireland which is part
of the UK and the Republic of Ireland
which is part of the European Union
that's always been a priority and so far
we've heard it in the report the
official stand is we're not going to
reopen the withdrawal agreement the
divorce agreement that's where this
backstop is anchored but what is going
to happen and that's the question we're
hearing a lot in Brussels and also we
are asking what is going to happen if
the alternative is between a No Deal
brexit where you automatically have a
border between Northern Ireland and
Ireland or let's say limit the backstop
in time maybe say five years what are
the Irish going to do then are they
going to cave in because everybody here
in the European Union will follow the
lead of Ireland in this because they are
the ones that are really going to get
hurt by this so I can tell you this so
far European unity still seems to hold
but I think it's safe to say that in the
back rooms a lot of people are talking
to the Irish at the moment absolutely a
lot of very important discussions going
on right now
Michaela what is the overall perception
though in Germany on what is going on
right now not only in the British
Parliament but also in Brussels well I
mean there's a big difference so the
look to Brussels really tells Berlin
that the European Union was more
successful in showing a united front
that many here would have expected
throughout these two years two years or
something for negotiations at the same
time there's a sense of frustrations
when looking towards London and there's
also a perception of that this is all a
political drama that is being staged
that Teresa may is now doing towards
Brussels what she's done towards her own
Parliament which is basically upping the
ante working as close to the deadline as
possible to forge some kind of
compromise because one thing is clear
just over a week ago we saw the German
Chancellor here saying there is still
time to talk well then if there's
nothing more to give why would you still
want to be talking so as Max pointed out
a lot of discussions a lot of scenarios
clearly being talked about right now but
nobody wants to give ground on the point
of principle and it's really worth
reminding that we're getting closer and
closer to that March 29th the deadline
that is the scheduled departure date of
the UK from the EU so max I'd like to
ask you because I mean you were talking
a little bit about the conversations
that are happening right now in
backrooms to try and get a compromise
but take us through what many in
Brussels see as the worst case scenario
the EU the UK rather crashing out of the
EU is the EU ready for that it's more
ready than the UK let's put it this way
they've been working on a number of
smaller agreements to have essential
ties with the UK up and running if they
crash out with a No Deal brexit let's
say for example for aviation one thing's
clear a No Deal brexit and the experts
who know about these things economic
experts really agree on this the UK
would be much worse off than the
European Union if there is a no deal
brexit but you know it's going to hurt
the European Union as well because of
the economic ties there so it's in
nobody's interest really okay thank you
so much that's Hoffmann in Brussels
Mikaela Kufner giving us some analysis
on the conversations that are happening
right now and the reaction to what was
decided in London yesterday we
appreciate it from both of you
you